over how to respond to the mass shooting
in colorado including gun legislation
that is unlikely to pass a closely
divided senate
but in the face of seemingly
insurmountable disagreements two female
senators are determined to find common
ground on at least some issues
west virginia republican shelley moore
capito and nevada democrat jackie rosen
are sharing their secrets to success
congressional correspondent nicole
killian spoke with them nicole good
morning to you
hey good morning to you tony as you know
here on capitol hill
bipartisanship is often hard to come by
particularly
in today's political climate but
senators capital and rosen are trying to
lead
by example both have been ranked as some
of the most bipartisan
members in the senate and they say the
key to their relationship
is finding common ground it can feel
like washington
doesn't work washington is completely
disappointed and
certainly doesn't work together
obstruction obstruction
but two senators from opposite sides of
the aisle and country
say they're not as far apart as you
think you're from nevada you're from
west virginia what's the connection we
get together we leave our politics and
our pocket books at the door
and we talk about the things that really
are important to us
as women well and i think we're doers i
think we like to get results
and so far they have whether it's
working on legislation to expand
broadband
or create more science and technology
opportunities for girls
according to a pro-public analysis of
their voting records in the last
congress
the democrat and republican duo agreed
about as often as they disagreed
49 to 51 percent that's probably better
than
our with our husbands i don't know
actually i think we get the 51
on the husband's side so let's take the
49
we agree and that's where we need to put
our our work
i would say we sort of avoid the really
high
intensity disagreements that we know
we're always going to have
we don't have to be disagreeable when we
disagree we can focus on the things we
agree on
that's why people send us here that's
what they expect from their leadership
you all make it sound so easy in terms
of
bipartisanship what are you doing that
some of your colleagues aren't i think
honestly if you're asking where i think
some of our other colleagues
unnamed could improve i think the way we
disagree
sometimes is very disrespectful
bipartisan effort
years ago retired maryland senator
barbara mikulski
started the tradition of organizing
bipartisan dinners
just for senate women and they've kept
them going
i'd love to see the whole senate do some
rotating dinners where you had to sit at
tables with people that you didn't talk
to
hear about their families and that's the
way you build bridges
to getting things done but the pandemic
has taken those dinners
off the table everything's pretty much
virtual we haven't had a virtual dinner
though maybe we're going to try that
covid isn't the only challenge that's
had a profound impact
so did january 6th we saw the rioters
climbing
up the capitol wall and we barricaded in
our offices
i was actually on the floor the sentinel
moment to me
was said they're taking the vice
president out of here
and that's when everything just sort of
fell apart
what was going through your head i
thought about 9 11.
because i was here on 9 11. i think
that's when i had the realization that
this is big why don't you think
congress can kind of rally around that i
mean when you draw comparisons to 9 11
will you look back at how the country
rallied then i can hear you
but on an issue of this magnitude why
still the divide
on 9 11 we had an external
force coming in on us this is something
within
our own country and maybe a little
tougher to heal i would almost argue
that we should go in a closed door
session and maybe each
person might share how they felt that
day i think it might give us that
way to bring us together emotionally
both are very clear-eyed about the
challenges
facing congress but they do believe that
there are
areas where democrats and republicans
can work together even
on big items like infrastructure and
immigration which could be the next big
test
for lawmakers gail i like how they're
thinking nicole they should tell the men
leave your politics in your pocketbooks
and just sit and talk luck gets done
thank you nicole